foreign
Portland as a child we all love Indiana
Jones but it was actually really in high
school when I was able to take an
anthropology class and it really piqued
my interest and then in Community
College I started taking archeology
classes
the coast is not forgiving to the
artifacts so we're finding they're often
broken up small chunks of what we would
find
even though we've got only fragments
they can really tell us where they were
made when and even who for
the first thing you notice about these
blue color designs is that they are
Chinese
so why were Chinese porcelains being
brought to Oregon we found the shirts
were from large plates and cups matching
European desire for large meals in mugs
of hot chocolate
this is likely a cup we don't really
know what the groove foot Rim was meant
to be or what the purpose of it is but
apparently it was a very big thing with
the European Market at the time
using all this data together we have
come to a mean date of 1690
and what's intriguing is that it's 120
years before any Europeans arrived in
Oregon
[Music]
speech on that side there's a lot of
porcelain that seems to be right so
basically what you're seeing is material
like directly on the opposite side of
where we currently are yeah so you've
recovered some porcelain yeah just north
of here just yeah lots of it yeah
so you know you go here to there to
there it kind of lines up you know
this is an underwater environment known
by local fishermen as a place where
they've hung Nets and that's always a
great indication of a place that could
be parts of a shipwreck are we clear
that's perfect okay
we're looking at the data as it's being
collected and nothing was obviously
sticking out I should have more coffee
pretty much
and suddenly we saw this one area where
there was this linear feature that
looked almost like the spines on the
back of a Stegosaurus there's definitely
something out here we're starting to
pick up already some linear features in
an otherwise Sandy environment yeah that
doesn't really look like rock oh here
already yeah here we're starting pickup
and a few more of those yeah it is four
or five meters long so maybe there's
another
maybe that's the broken Mast yeah oh
look it's got a hollow shadow that was a
little Notch out in this this is really
yeah you probably see it in there oh oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa look at that look at
it up here look at the bow you can see
that almost looks like
sometimes x marks the spot could that be
the beeswax it could be
[Music]